[Musique]
les prix de la baleine augmentent, les prix
du transport continuent également et
vous pouvez alors voir les dommages que les
véhicules normaux font les véhicules à essence que les
véhicules à moteur diesel
causent à notre environnement, alors j'ai
proposé cette technologie pour résoudre tout
cela  problème
[Musique]
toutes les deux semaines, tous les véhicules
viendront pour les mainteneurs, donc ce que nous faisons
ici pour la maintenance est de vérifier le
niveau de la batterie pour vérifier que toutes les batteries
sont bien serrées
pour vérifier le système d'imagerie de la batterie bmx
s'ils fonctionnent bien ou pour  voyez s'il y a
des dommages et une connexion ou
s'il y a une perte de
puissance des piles
[Musique] que
vous